the chairing this morning's session and
to introduce uh Terry C who's kindly AG
to talk to us on the entropy detriment
method and the UST discrepency problem
thank you Cherry thanks Tom thanks for
inviting
me uh right so I'll be talking about uh
as Tom said the uh briish discrepancy
problem um
solved although uh for this particular
talk um be focusing Less on this actual
problem and more on the technique you
used to prove it which is something I
call the entropy decrement
argument which is something that I
invented in order to prove this um but
to solve this question but I think it
should have more applications than just
this one uh this this one problem so I'm
want to focus emphasize this method so
this method is kind of you know in the
spirit of this structur and Randomness
um Workshop it's similar to other
methods used in um um whenever you want
to exploit somehow the dichotomy between
structure and Randomness know so there
are other methods which go by the names
of the the density increment argument
for example of
Roth so this is what Roth used to show
that every dense set of integers
contains progression than three um so
you know the idea is that if you have a
set with some irregularity you can use
it to find a subset with higher density
in some uh uh in some progression or
something and then there are these
energy incent
arguments okay use for example to I'm
ready to regularity
LMA very similar thing if you have say a
graph which has some irregularity in it
you can use it to find a partition which
which increases some energy some index
of graph um yeah then there are these
things like the these these these rank
reduction
arguments I use all over the
place uh if you have a bunch of
functions a bunch of objects or vectors
which have some um um correlation or
some constraint uh between the between
them you can you can you can use that
constraint to eliminate one of your
variables reduce the rank of your object
by one um so that's used all over the
place um and then um this this is uh
what I call the entropy compression
method they use to prove it to give a
nice new proof of the Lash locala uh
where again if if if something doesn't
if something bad happens that that you
can't satisfy certain set of set of um
of of sentences for instance you can use
that to to compress the entropy of some
random variable
okay so so this argument is sort of I
think of it as just sort of a a sibling
of of the of these arguments here and
hopefully that'll become clearer when I
uh actually show it to you okay so first
of all what is the UR discrepancy
problem um so it's a problem about
homogeneous Artic
progressions arithmetic
progressions which start at zero or
actually they don't start at zero but
but they um the starting point is the
same is the same as as as their step
okay so um they they progressions of
this form and the urish discrepancy
problem is whether you can make a sign
pattern which is balanced on all of
these um these progressions so the
question is that does there
exist a sequence F from the natural
numbers to plus and minus one
which is very balanced on on all these
progressions okay such that all these uh
when you sum your function on every
single arthic
progression uh it's always
bounded so in other words uh the superp
of or
D&J
you know so you can make a sequence
which is bounded on some of these
progressions you know for example um if
you only look at progressions spacing
one 1 2 3 up to J you can easily make a
sequence which is um for which the sums
on which all the par sums are bounded
you just take the alence one Min - one 1
- one one - one that will be bounded on
every progression step of spacing one
but it won't be bounded on on
progression of spacing two and so the
question is can you can you do this um
okay and ter the answer is no
okay this is what I
showed about few years ago now um okay
previous to this uh the best known laow
bound on this quantity was
three um that uh that this this the
sequence had to have discrep so this is
called the discrepancy of your sequence
uh the discrepancy of the sequence had
to be at least three and that was hard
actually this this was done by conov and
la
ti only one year
before so so two is fairly easy okay so
that's actually a nice nice uh exercise
if you if you're bored uh you prove a
contradiction you assume that the sum is
always at most one um and then you have
this sort of fairly easy problem uh
uh to show that uh that you get a
contradiction after a while um yeah to
to uh to solve uh to get this lower
bound kind of in the S had to solve this
massive threat problem um and it's a
computer it's a computer assisted proof
uh the proof actually has the mon of
being the the largest proof uh in in
mathematics the the the actual file that
verifies uh the three side thing is is
is is a couple gigabytes anyway
um okay so um all right so so this this
this is the uh the discrepancy problem
um so I won't focus so much on on on on
the on the full um problem but I'll just
focus on one model model case Okay so so
uh so model problem
okay so this is a statement about
arbitrary sequences but let's take of
very special sequence okay so let's take
F to be What's called the Lal
function okay so um the Lal function of
n is defined to be uh plus one when n is
um is the product of of an even number
of
primes actually let's just let's just
say
it's min-1 to the
K if n is the product of K of K primes
so Lambda of 6 is plus one Lambda of 9
is plus one lamb of 7 is minus one so
forth okay so that's a sequence of plus
and minus ones it's a very special
sequence um so it it has the property of
being completely
implicative Mullica
function
okay and it's it's negative one at every
Prime so in particular for example
Lambda 2
N isus Lambda of n l 3
n minus lamb of N and so forth okay so
it has these special properties in fact
these properties basically essentially
Define function uniquely um so for this
particular function these partial sums
simplify if you if if you
take
uh if you take the partial sums of the
Lal function on homogeneous progression
because of complete multiplicativity the
Lambda of I just comes out as a factor
but it's plus or minus one so it doesn't
actually affect the
sum sry l d comes
out okay so um yeah so the spacing is
actually Irrelevant in the case of of of
Lambda of the Lal function and so the
model question is just are the partial
sums of louvo
unbounded um so this was already known
okay so so um yeah so yeah the answer
here is is yes and this is this is quite
classical um you could um you can prove
it fairly easily using the theory of Rin
zeta
function
okay so the L function happens to to
obey a certain
identity and you can relate the Lal
function to the rean zeta function um
and then if you play around with piron's
formula and and and and you understand
something about the zeros of the zeta
function we don't know everything but we
know something but Zer the zeta function
you can you can easily get um some some
some Unbound in fact we can show that
usually it's bigger than than D times
some log factor which I
forget
um okay so uh so this was already known
but uh the model problem is to prove
this without using this this fact okay
okay yeah prove
this
without using the zeta function okay
basically well uh without using okay
without using specifically this well
okay um well it's a bit vague what with
without using means but okay
um um in particular you would like an
argument which works for other
completely multiplicative functions than
the lual
function which you don't necessarily
have a nice relationship with the zeta
function okay so um I'm going to focus
on this model problem um it turns out
you can reduce the uh roughly speaking
the general case uh if if if you can
prove unboundedness for all complete M
multiplicative function
in a sufficiently uniform way and I want
to specify what uniform means then it
actually implies the general um that
Unbound for for the general sums um
roughly speaking the way you do that is
that a general function is not
completely multiplicative but using uh F
analysis you can roughly speaking break
up um your function as a superposition
of complete M functions um and then if
you pick D randomly um the the um uh the
complete mul components of your
functions kind of decouple um on average
uh if you if you take some second moment
in in in in the D parameter and if if
each of the each of the the random each
of the multiplicative functions that
that show up unbounded sums in a
sufficient uniform manner you can
actually show that that this sum on
average is also
unbounded um but um and so this actually
that was worked out earlier than um than
my work so there was a previous attempt
to solve this problem by Tim gal's
polymath project um and they didn't
solve this problem but they they did
achieve this observation that if if um
if you wanted to prove the general case
basically it sufficed roughly speaking
to prove the uh to prove um the uh the
conjecture for um multiplicative
functions um not just the Lal function
but I'm just going to focus on the L
function for
Simplicity
okay all right um so I'm going to think
of this in problemistic
terms so you can sort of um
take uh say
interpretation so um the way I'm going
to think about this is is I'm going to
pick a large number
X going to
Infinity um and then you pick
a okay and then uh you pick a number n
at random pick natur number n at
random
on to X um so lambin okay so so what
what this does is that it it it produces
um um a stationary process so you then
you then look
at
um the sequence the um the sign pattern
of the L function near n so you've got
um so you take Lambda of n that's that's
some random that's some random number
plus or minus one this is another number
plus or minus one
okay so for every random number you will
generate some some random sequence of
signs okay and as n n shifts around you
get a different sequence of signs so you
get um you get a process you you get um
you you get pattern of signs and it's
basically stationary uh what that means
is that is that if you shift the
sequence by if you shift this random
sequence by one or by two or whatever
you get another sequence which has the
same distribution as Al in the limit as
X goes Infinity as the original sequence
so it gives you some some some
stationing process of
science Asic stationary process of
Science and um rather than look at at at
the full partial sums from one all the
way up up to some big number D we'll
just look as short partial
sums
okay so we'll look at at we have take
some medium siiz H you know like 100 or
something we we look at at at um at
these partial sums and so so this is a
random variable okay so because n is
random um and basically we want to ask
are these random variables unbounded
okay H okay so of course when you fixed
H they're bounded by H but um but does
the bound grow in ag okay um so if if
you can show that this random variable
becomes can become arbitrary large as as
as H increases then that implies that
partial sums must be unbounded okay so
um we can you can just have a look at
each individual at sort of sums of
random variables
okay all right so each individual um
random variable is easy to understand um
if you pick a random number
uh if you pick a random n um Lambda of n
is plus or minus one um on average it's
uh ASM totically it has mean zero this
is the prime number
theorem so the prime number theorem has
an equivalent form due to
landal
um that on average the Luber function is
has is is is is balanced it has plus
minus ones in basically 50/50 um% of the
time okay strictly speaking okay I've
already used the okay you want to prove
that you have to use this but um uh okay
but but this uh
um somehow less uh I'm using this less
than than uh than
uh the direct way to prove Unbound using
its identity but U anyway Lambda is uh
is is is balanced um and of course it's
plus or minus one so so it's it's it's
variant
therefore is basically
one because the absolute value Lambda
squ is always
one okay so each of these random
variables is a random is a basically a
Bui random variable it has mean zero and
variance one okay um so if all of these
random variables were independent um
then life would be very easy because if
you sum n independent variables um then
the um H in variables the sum here would
a VAR is H um and so hence it must be at
least as big as root H some of the time
and root H is unbounded so so you're
done okay um so so if we knew okay so if
we
knew we had correlation estimates okay
if if if we
knew that any two random variables let's
say Lambda n and Lambda n plus h uh were
um were ASM totically uncorrelated that
that that their mean was was little of
one so their covariance was was little
of one um then we'd be done okay yeah
then
some and variance
H is
unbounded and we're done okay so um this
is believed to be true um so there's
this heuristic called the the mobus
randomness hypothesis which in this case
would actually be the louvo randomness
hypothesis uh which basically um
predicts that that these um among other
things that that these random variables
uh so that these actually um independ
these random variables actually do
behave like like independent random
variables um so for instance if you take
Lambda n and then n plus
one yeah so yeah okay
um it's believed that that you just you
just take two of these these these
random variables say two consecutive
ones
um they should so there's four there's
four four different values that this
pair can take plus one plus one plus one
minus one um- one- one- one plus one
it's believed that they're equ
distributed so any each sign pattern
should occur one qu of the
time this this is
um and and similarly for um for longer
patterns if I take sign pattern of of
length H every sign pattern should occur
with probably one of a two to the AG um
ASM totically this is actually called
the Chala
conjecture okay so um so this is not
known okay so so it's it's it's it's
known for one okay so because of the
prime number theorem each individual
sign would be plus one or minus one
probably one half but um there could be
correlations between um individual
elements and potentially these
correlations um would uh uh would maybe
conspire to to make this
some okay so uh this is this is
unfortunately not known um if it was
known it would would be done at least
for this model
problem okay but uh what I was able to
show was so um in in
um uh in nonprofit notation what what uh
so another way of of stating this sort
of conjecture is that if I take say
Lambda n Lambda n +
okay so uh the conjection is that if you
sum Lambda n * Lambda plus 1 from n up
to X it's supposed to be l o x x is the
trivial bound you want to gain a little
o of the TR so that's not known but what
I was able to show uh two years
ago there's a smooth out version of this
what I call a log of think average
version of
this okay if you uh if you sum this
harmonically you put a one/ n here um
then the trivial bound here is is is log
X okay the harmonic series and so I was
able to get a little o for this average
version uh that's weaker than than this
bound if you have this bound then a some
bit of summation my parts gives you this
bound but it doesn't go the other way
around this is a smoother sum um and it
turns out that that this is good enough
uh at least for the application to prove
unboundedness that that if you can prove
this uh so what you do is is that
instead of sampling n uniformly from one
to X you sample n with this harmonic
weight and you're on the same argument
and um and you you still get this
unboundedness um so so this is good
enough so so I had this sort of logic
average version of the childa conjecture
um so far it only works for for pair
correlations I would love to extend this
to to three. four point correlations
that's uh very optimistically work in
progress which basically means we don't
know how to do it but um okay but um
well okay that's another story but um
okay but I can at least get the pair
corations okay
um
all right so before I talk about my
proof um so you can use okay so so
basically the uh the idea is you have to
start using um properties of the lvo
function okay so you know if you take an
arbitrary sequence of plus minus on
there is there is no reason um you know
so for example you know you could take
the outter sequence plus one minus one
plus one minus one plus one minus one
right there the partial sums are bounded
and there you have plenty of correlation
between cons elements but that sequence
is not completely multiplicative it
doesn't obey these properties and so you
want to um uh use somehow these facts
about the lvo
function okay so um so let me give you a
simple example how you can use that so
here's an
observation well not in this language
but essentially due to
Harmon
P okay so if you sound n l logically so
if n is
sample so yeah what that means is that
the probility of of n being any given
value n is one on N divided by the sum
of N N up to
X okay so you you sample using this this
so harmonic distribution up to X okay
then it sampled logarithmically
then um the probability that Lambda of N
and Lambda of n + one that they are
equal um so um this should be one half
okay so so conjecturally this is a
random sign this is a random sign they
should behave like one half but what you
can do fairly
easily a low B 1/3
that's okay um and so why is this um so
what we're going to do is that
um
let's first look at
uh this
probability okay so rather than look at
the probability that n and n plus one
have have the same side let's look at
the probility that 2 N and 2 N plus one
have the same side so I claim that this
is basically the same as the probability
that n and n plus one of the same
sign and N is divisible by
two well by
two okay um so yeah the prob that that 2
N and 2 N plus one the same sign is
basically twice the prob n and n plus
one of the same sign and N is even um so
why this is the case we're just going to
write down Okay so let's actually write
out what what all these expressions mean
okay so so what this is I'm summing of
all n less than x 1/
n times uh I guess the indicator of
Lambda 2 2
n 2 +
1 okay and then I have to divide by a
factor which is basically log
X okay so so up to Small errors that's
what uh that's what this expression is
uh and up to Small errors what this is
is this this is again one of log X over
here n less than x uh
twice indicated a function of Lambda of
n one being the same and uh n is
even
okay so um to make these look the same
um so I guess I can I can do here okay
so you know if you make the change of
variables m equals 2 N okay if you if
you if you start this sum and you make
the change of
variables uh yeah then what this is this
is one of a log
X N is less than x than m is less than
2x uh and function Lambda of
M is Lambda of m + 1 and M is
even div by n but dividing by n is
diving by m m by two okay and when you
compare that with what you have over
here it's almost the same except that
your range is now ranging over 2x rather
than overx now if you were doing
ordinary averaging this would be a big
problem um but when when you're doing
logic averaging the um averaging over X
and averaging over 2x is almost the same
because the the error is of size one and
one over log X goes to zero so because
of this log averaging um that that is
negligible and that's what gives you
this this sort of here okay so so um
Lambda 2 plus so so so this event has
the same probability as twice this
event
okay and
um very
similarly the probability that 2 n + 1
and 2 n + 2 the same sign pattern this
is twice the probability that l n and l
n + one are equal and uh n is
odd a very similar
argument okay and then finally uh if you
look at the probability that Lambda of 2
N and 2 n + 2 are
equal um here you can use
multiplicativity okay I haven't use that
yet if lamb 2 and lamb 2 plus 2 are
equal that's exactly the same as n and n
plus one being
equal so we have these three
identities on the other hand from the
pigeon principle okay if you look at
lamb n so Lambda 2 N Lambda 2 n+ 1
Lambda 2 + 2 these are three signs of Si
plusus one two of them have to be equal
no matter what okay so the sum of these
three probabilities has to be at least
one okay so if you add that up um that
tells you that basically three times
this probably has to be at least one and
that's what that's what gives you this
this little am here okay so that's a
simple example of how you can use um
first of all use this log averaging but
also use the properties of um the
multiplicative properties of your lual
function to to get to get at least some
partial progress towards what you want
so I mean that doesn't get you all the
way to little of one but it gives you
something so
um okay ask about the opposite
probability about the probity that
they're different um are there any lower
bounds from that so there is a lower
Bound for
some but this was this actually was is
very
recent
I forget where the accent goes um maybe
okay um all
right okay so um yeah in in the opposite
direction the um um changes of sign also
are known to ur of positive probability
but but this is very recent uh it was
only known in
2015 um because um kaiso and Max Mamaki
and Mell um what they proved this is a
Cory of a really nice theorem um of
their that um that showed something
about these partial sums so um they show
that these partial sums um over here um
well um so yeah what they showed is is
that uh okay if you take these partial
sums and you look at how they fluctuate
so there's a trivial bound of
H um but uh but you can actually get a
little bit better okay so I think I
think they can get something like like
um like logage to a to a small power
okay
there there's a little bit of a gain um
um that uh that these partial sums
cannnot um um must have some
cancellation eventually if H gets big
enough okay so this is a difficult
theorem um and yeah that uses lots and
lots of of sort of well not quite Zeta
functions but series technology so I'll
just take this as given um so um once
you have this then you can prove this
because suppose this wasn't true okay
you know so suppose instead you know if
if if this was not true um that that if
the probability of Lambda of n changing
sign with Lambda n plus one was was tiny
little of one what that would mean is
that almost you know 99% of the time
Lambda of N and then n plus one have the
same side and then for any fixed H with
probability close to one this sum would
have no cancellation this sum would be
size Ag and you would eventually get a
contradiction okay so so by using this
this rather deep um bound here this is
this is quite non-trivial U they could
also get um some low Bound in the other
direction okay and it's possible to play
around and you can use further ad hoc
methods like this um you can also work
with um um triples so um
yeah so
um with M Mak R we're able to show
similar things for three term sign
patterns um
for for any choice of sign
pattern three every sign pattern
occurred with positive probability and
basically by more complicated versions
of of this argument um it was actually a
lot like solving a giant to doku puzzle
you know this this is sort of
you can sort of see a type type
situation happening here you know that
that that the you know when I said the
pigal principle told you that that that
one of these three statements had to be
true that's kind of a type type
think and there's a certain threat type
type game you can play um which uh which
which gives you this but uh it was
really not not clear at all that this
would extend at all to four was very ad
hoc
um all right
this buil on earlier work of Hilder
Brown um several decades earlier who
showed at least that each the patterns
occurred infinitely often but uh but
they didn't get they didn't have the
positive density because that that
needed this the of M
Mak
okay so um
the okay so the the way okay so coming
back to yeah so um so we
want okay so so so we have this model
problem okay we want toh to understand
the correlation between just say
adjacent elements of the Lal function um
so this is just a single sum um you
would like to um
um so there's not much you can do with a
single sum so you want to try to average
it to make it to get more
cancellation um so you can you can
average this this expression using some
of the
symmetries of of um of the problem so
for example um there translation
symmetry this Aver is also the same as
as L of n plus one n plus two up to a
tiny error
and so
forth you can shift your because it's a
stationary process you can shift your
correlation around and so if you
like you can average let's say um J from
one to
H this single pair correlation you can
reexpress up up to Small errors as an
average of of pair correlations now this
by itself doesn't um help you because
this could still be be big okay so again
in the example where where Lamb's
outting plus oneus one plus one- one
plus one minus one you know this
Coalition is always minus one but so
it's so all these guys there's still no
cancellation um so a single average by
itself is often not enough to get
cancellation but when you have two
averages when you have a double average
then you can start playing games you Cy
Schwartz and circle method and so forth
there there are lots of tricks for how
to exploit double averages but when you
have single average um that's someh not
enough um structure
yet so but so far we haven't used the um
multiplicativity the fact that Lambda is
multiplicative okay so what we can
do so we know that for any Prime P
Lambda PN is the same as minus Lambda of
n okay so this this probability we can
also
write as Lambda PN
Lambda of PN plus
P okay just by using this this property
twice okay and this is the same by sort
of similar argument to what I had before
this is Bally P times the
probability Lambda of n and n plus
p
uh restricted to uh to to n being
divisible by
P so by similar argument to what I had
over there the the the explication of
this quantity is by change of variables
basically and using the fact that we
have log averaging this is basically P *
um times this correlation with this with
this annoying
restriction okay so um so this is
another symmetry you have so if you
combine these two symmetries or what you
get you can write this correlation it's
a double
average
that for any H for any H not too big
okay
um this single
correlation you can write as
um double correlation so on the one hand
you're
averaging let's say um J between h/ 2
and H 4 okay so then I get
the average over primes less than
h/2 sorry uh this is
H2 h 2 so 2 log
H H never mind these averaging factors
um Lambda of n + J Lambda of n plus j+
p p * indicat function of n plus j0
p so if you combine both the dilation
invariance that's happening here and the
translation invariance that was used
here you can get a double average um you
can replace a single correlation by a
double average of correlations um
between different um points of your sign
pattern so so um um you look at the sign
pattern at position J and the sign
pattern at position J plus P um and you
call it these but you call them um
together with additional annoying Factor
here okay so um yeah up to
small so using the multiplicativity you
can convert this single average into
this this mess
here now what's particularly bad about
this mess is this quantity here um this
this this is this is uh this is very
annoying um on average this is
one n is is moving n is selected
randomly okay if he is a small Prime as
as n moves randomly this indicative
function will be will be one one pie of
the time and zero elsewhere so this this
quantity has has has U point on the
average so um okay if we would if we
could actually delete this Factor we
could replace it by one then this is a
much much easier
expression um so so now now this is a
double average like this um P ised to be
prime but if if you um ignore the fact
that you're Prime okay so if if this was
averaging if P was actually ranging over
all numbers from one to to H over two um
then you basically just averaging of
you're correlating over over all pairs n
plus J N plus J plus P between one and H
and this would basically
be of something like one of it's it's
it's it's cheating a little
bit but this double sum here if you
ignore the fact that P is prime it looks
a lot like the square of a single of a
single average um and that's that we
know to be small because of this
okay the single averages are usually
small and so this this is
fine now there is uh P reut Prime but
but we know how to deal with that okay
so so the magic is a circle method okay
so if you apply the circle method to
this you have to use a slightly more
General version of this the um you can
show that that that if you can ignore
this Factor here that this expression is
small so the um the problem is is this
additional um this this additional
Factor here so another way saying it is
that you subtract the mean
here okay so the um the main difficulty
is to show that these correlations
weighted by this by this annoying extra
Factor here okay I want to show that
these correlations are
small okay so here is finally where
entropy comes in okay so so there's been
no entropy at all
um okay so this is a MTH but abstractly
um what this expression is is is it it
is some combination of two different
random
variables so there there's really two
random varibles that are somehow
fighting here okay so I mean what um so
of course you have this original Source
Rand varable n
um okay but it gives you two two
different um random variables okay so
one of them I'm going to call x sub H
which is the sign
pattern
okay so on the one hand you have the
sign pattern every random number n gives
you some length H sign pattern which so
this this is some this is some Rand we
taking values in minus one plus in a
cube okay so there's a sign pattern
floating around there which we don't
understand very well um and that's what
sort of determines this this portion of
of that that controls this portion of
this sum and then there's there's
another vom varable which called y sub h
and these are the congruence classes of
n mod P for all primes P oh I need
it so you take this random variable and
you look at um at all congruence classes
um residue classes mod P over all the
Primes in this range and so so that
that's that lives in in something it
lives in some product of of C
PC
okay so these resue classes determine
this this portion of the random variable
of the sum so this whole expression just
abstractly you can think of it's just
some explicit function of these two
variables okay and the question is can
you make this expectation small okay um
all
right here's where you can start
using so the whole problem is that these
vandom variables are coupled together
because they both come from the same um
Source random varable so they're not
independent okay but if okay if uh these
random vars were
independent um then it turns out that uh
that you can make this really
small this is small with really high
probability one minus expon actually
let's put this way it's less than
Epsilon probably exponential in minus
Epsilon time the number of primes which
is H log
X so there's an exponentially small
failure rate okay that that this
expression will be um very tiny if these
were independent um and this basically
comes from hting
inequality see the reason is you know
this ROM varable we don't understand
okay in fact understanding this is
basically the whole point of this
exercise is to try to understand this
random variable but this ROM variable we
understand very well okay that that as n
ranges from one to X and if x is huge
this R was basically uniformly
distributed over this um um this um the
set here so in other words you can think
of n p as as just basically independent
am variables that un distributed so each
of these Expressions here are
independent random variables with mean
zero um and if uh if this junk here is
independent of of of this stuff here
then you can use hope things inequality
and get some concentration okay so um so
if these were not correlated so stronger
than not correlated if they were
independent um then
um uh then you would you would have um
uh you you would win with with a huge
gain in
fact
so how can you how can you not win okay
so so um all right so this is like the
the randomness portion of the deconomy
okay see so what is the opposite
structured part of the of of of economy
so so suppose suppose you don't win
suppose this is very biased that that on
average this is very big um what this
means is that whenever you fix a sign
pattern whenever you condition xh to be
fixed you there's so much correlation
between xh and Y that when you fix um
the sign pattern of xh this R variable
is no longer uniform distributed but it
has become concentrated into an
exponentially smaller set that that that
that there must be um a lot of
dependence between these random
variables that that that fixing xh um
reduces the entropy of of of YH quite a
bit okay so so by playing around with
entropy inequalities what you can show
is that
if if this is
big
and um the entropy of YH given xh has to
be a lot less than the entg of YH
alone like
this that that that uh that this sign
pattern must somehow remove Epsilon h of
log bits of entropy from from your um
your random variable in order to to
squeeze y YH into the the the the set of
failure of the hting inequality okay so
okay so that wasn't quite a proof you
want to make a proof you have to use
something called the data processing
inequality okay but but uh okay but but
there is um some um um um reduction of
of of of entropy here um this is the
Shannon entropy of of of of of these
Expressions here um and this is pretty
big so you know um YH so you know just
for comparison the the entropy of YH
it's basically H okay it's it's the the
log of the size of of of the set which
is by the prim basically exponential H
um and um also xh the sign pattern is
well it's it's it's at most H okay so
you know it it takes values in um in in
this Cube so which also exponential in h
it may be concentrated to a much smaller
set but the ENT at most H so there's a
big chunk of of of of of correlation
here another way of saying this an
equivalent way of saying this is that
the the mutual
information between between these two an
varibles is
Big M information that def the
difference between between these
quantities here okay so so um somehow
the you know this has basically H bits
of entropy this is H bits of entropy but
h of log H bits of entropy are common
okay so this is the structure and you
you want to use this
somehow
so you want to to use this to decrease
something to right that's the entropy
decent
so the way you
proceed so so first of all um the this
entropy here the the the word entropy of
of the sign pattern um it has a a sub
additivity property like the the the
entropy of
um
string of l h is at most twice the enty
of of of sorry the entropy of a of a
string of a 2 H is at most the twice the
entropy of of size H the reason is that
you can think of X X2 as basically a
string of length H is basically a
concatenation
of string length H and then another
string of length H just shifted by H
okay and the shanon entropy in equality
is tell you the entropy of of of a pair
it's always bounded by the entropy of
the two
pieces okay and because of stationarity
this is the same as this and so so these
are so there is a sub additivity of ENT
which is very well known um but um if if
if you have this sort of shared
information um then you can you can
improve this bound here
um so let's see how does this go
um so I think what I
want is that uh once you have this
shared information
um yeah I can bound this this Quant so
um y2h given YH I can bound I can I can
get a better bound than okay so this
again is
H so same
argument
all right so um I have this this plus
this now um this expression is the same
again as xh
YH see xh Prime again has the same
distribution as X xh and YH doesn't
change you know um the when you shift n
by a constant the the new R variable the
new YH is the same has the same um
information carries the same information
as the old
YH there there's no new entropy produced
there so so these are equal so this is
twice y um and this is the same as twice
inte of
x minus twice the mutual information of
xh and
YH okay mut is symmetric so it's the mut
is the difference between YH and
conditional y but it's also the
difference between xh and conditional
xh so what you see um so maybe if I if I
normalize it okay if you look at the the
mean entropy of of of x2h conditional
here there there's a there's a
decrease minus an Epsilon over log
H so you divide by H the mean entropy
over here uh you have to do this little
bit of conditioning um is less than the
there's a decrease in the mean entropy
by this certain Factor here
okay um so now what you can do is that
you basically iterate this in
h so you replace H by 2 H 4 h 8 H and so
forth um okay so it's it's slightly kny
that that these um um uh the left hand
side my hand don't quite agree so so so
actually what you have to do is you have
to condition not only on y but but on on
on all the previous Wes as
well so there's a variant of this
inquality that I just mentioned where um
where you also condition on on all the
previous um resue classes but because of
the Chinese remainder theorem that
everything still goes through um but now
it iterates so you can you can keep um
you can keep iterating this these
expressions are all bounded because the
entropy is always at most H so these all
bound by one but as H increases by pow
of two this um this decent is um
diverges
it's barely but it does diverge okay um
log when H is POS of two one log H is
like one over J and there's harmonic
series that diverges So eventually you
run out of entropy okay so so so you you
pick some H if there is structure at
scale H that means that there was some
some of the information some some of the
entropy of the sign pattern which you
don't understand is being absorbed by
these particular residue classes um and
so that that that takes away some of the
entropy and it it it makes it makes the
entropy of obious sequence grow more
slowly than than it would have if if
there wasn't this uh this um um ENT
trapped by this sort of zero entropy
sequence here um but uh um okay but then
you go on to the next scale and at each
scale more and more of the entropy or of
is is sort of locked away in these
periodic um random variables here um
until there was there was no entropy
left okay or at Le no mean entropy left
um and then so so this gives you
contradiction
enough okay um unless okay that that's
if all these expectations were were big
and so that tells you that some for some
scale um at some scale this inter was
small and that's what what makes the
argument work so that's the ENT de
argument I think it's uh yeah so so
basically the idea is when you have two
random variables and they're not uh and
You' love them to be independent um and
uh but you can't guarantee that you can
sometimes use that you know use the
non-independence to to trap some entropy
and if you can keep iterating that you
can get a contradiction that that is
this entropy document argument I'm
hoping it can be used for something else
other than this problem okay I think I'm
out of time so thank you very
much any questions for ter so so like in
CS we we we do often like try to prove
something assuming everything random
even when it's not and then go back and
look at the spots where we use
Randomness and like substitute the
correct notion of pseudo Randomness
likewise
and so kind of in this it looks like we
get to hopings inequality assume it's
random and then is there an appropriate
notion of pseudo Randomness that you're
kind of proving here with your energy
decrement argument yes so pseudo
Randomness in this case is is is small
Mutual information okay that's it's it's
a fairly weak notion of of of
Independence
yeah
can you say something about quantity
defance um not much uh yeah so um I
think I I
I yeah for example if you wanted to
control uh
no many steps I think um if you wanted
to
control this I think for this paration
already I think it's like a log through
log four four or four log them um
because basically the Divergence of this
is so slow um also at some point I have
to use the M that also loses Another Log
um although maybe there was a loss in
parallel rather than sequentially but
okay um okay that feeds back into other
things um so the uh the reduction from
multiplicative functions to General
functions for the it discy I think that
loses Another Log or two so all the
bounds have some iterator log in them
but uh it's there's certainly no way you
need the optimal so I can to optimize
how many logs you
lose how sensitive is what you did over
here to the quality of the tail B yes
yeah no it's it's quite sensitive uh
yeah so if the failure rate was like log
squared um I I this wouldn't
work uh because the entropy I take out
at every stage now now is bounded um so
I was somehow yeah I was lucky um that
uh the the quality basically there
enough primes I needed the prime I need
that there's enough primes at every
stage um so yeah actually it's a like I
need enough cries for for for for for
oil those thing to be true okay that the
sum of of primes diverged um roughly
speaking each prime sort of takes out
one of a p bits of entropy from from the
system um yeah so um yeah it only works
if you have a really good concentration
estimate um yeah so you definitely need
exponential quality at least but or very
close to
exponential is it obvious that the
normalized partial sums are bounded like
say normalized by one overare root of
the
length C so yours is that the soup
diverge whe whether these are
bounded that uh no that's the we
hypothesis uh well not quite okay
hypothesis this x that's equivalent to
we hypothesis yeah no the uh the best
bound known on the PO sums right
now X
exponential oh actually I don't remember
um okay this this this may not quite be
right okay there there was some uh game
which is of the shape
um I don't quite remember exactly what
it
is some game but but uh you know but but
but even a power gain that would be huge
that would be huge
progress
all right well if there any more
questions let's thank Terry
again